[Music]  let's welcome  Martellus to the gridiron hates writers  room we're so excited to have him  executive producing and writing and  directing episode 3 of 3 just being  retired and I thought it'd be really  funny to check into a retirement home  with guys who are already retired well  you should have great Louis like will  not move into the retirement home crime  dropped 104 sick and then I could leg  well you can see Cuddy like I'm walking  by the background I'm doing Martin I'm  doing all my lines first you're retired  it's not safe for you to be on your own  I survived to 28 to 3 deficit cigarette  there we go miss communicating again my  in season record 2500 and I think I  could be dead now retired athletes have  no love yes a full Marty episode